des manifestants toujours motivés après
des semaines de mobilisation l'objectif
n'a pas changé faire reculer le
gouvernement sur sa réforme qui ferait
passer l'âge de départ à la retraite de
62 à 64 ans
à chaque fois et là je pense je trouve
que 62 c'est bien c'est moi pour moi
c'est très bien 62 ans la colère sociale
la colère du monde du travail fasse une
réforme injuste il est toujours aussi
puissante
à Paris la manifestation a été marquée
par quelques épisodes de tension mais
surtout par un regain de la
participation dans certaines régions du
pays syndicat et autorité évoque même
des records mais cette forte
mobilisation n'a pas réussi à faire
reculer le gouvernement à partir
d'aujourd'hui les syndicats évoquent
donc un changement de stratégie on a
vraiment le sentiment
nos politiques ils veulent nous
expliquer des choses qu'on a très bien
compris donc finalement c'est un
dialogue de sourd pour faire pression
sur le gouvernement les syndicats ne
mise pas uniquement sur ces
manifestations à travers le pays mais
aussi sur des grèves qui affectent les
activités de plusieurs secteurs de
l'économie notamment celui des
transports
à Paris l'horaire des métros était
fortement imperturbé à travers le pays
seul un train sur 5 était en activité
je suis arrivé à 1h de 1h30 dans la
capitale des employés de la voirie se
sont aussi joints au mouvement dans
plusieurs secteurs de la ville les
déchets n'ont pas été collectés
la grève a aussi touché le secteur de
l'énergie les acheminements ont été
bloqués dans les raffineries rien pour
faire bouger le gouvernement ce que nous
faisons permet la pérennité du système
par répartition et permet de garantir la
solidarité intergénérationnelle
c'est que le mouvement contestation est
loin de s'essouffler la grève se
poursuivra en partie demain les
raffineries devraient toujours être
bloquées et les transports de nouveaux
perturbés cette Parisienne équipée de
son vélo si est préparé c'est vrai que
de dire combien de temps elle devra
l'utiliser les syndicats promettent une
mobilisation qui s'inscrira dans la
durée ici rafale Bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada à Paris